Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
Show, I'm Faren cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today.
Well, one thing that I've always been curious
about with the Q conspiracy folks, you know,
the whole idea that the federal government
is secretly being run by this cabal of pedophiles
and the Donald Trump himself was chosen to
weed them out.
The thing that always kind of bugs me about
this is why are they so silent when actual
Republicans get busted?
For essentially the same thing they're accusing
the Democrats of doing in the past five days,
we have now seen two.
High profile Republicans, one of them just
19 years old, arrested.
For allegedly trafficking minors for sex.
The big one was last week, 30 year old Anton
Lázaro from Minnesota was arrested on charges
of well, here it is.
I read this from law and crime.
The indictment charges Lázaro with one count
of conspiracy to commit sex trafficking minors,
five counts of sex trafficking of minors,
one count of attempted sex trafficking of
a minor, and three counts of obstruction.
Based on the evidence obtained in this investigation,
authorities believe there may be additional
victims of the alleged conduct.
Now, Mr. Lazaro actually served as an alternate
elector in 2020 for Donald Trump.
He has given hundreds of thousands of dollars
to Republican candidates over the years, and
he has been a major player in Republican politics
in the state of Minnesota.
And this report, this arrest was so damning
that the Republicans he's donated money to
over the years have been forced to come out
and say, well, we're going to donate the money
to charity.
Now, whatever he had given us, we're going
to donate that same amount to charity.
Hopefully it's charities that take care of
victims of sex trafficking.
But then actually just a couple miles from
where I'm sitting right now, you had another
Republican from Minnesota arrested down here
in Florida.
And that person was a 19 year old, Gizella
Castro Medina of St. Paul, Minnesota.
She's a leader with the Minnesota College
Republicans, which is a governing group of
young political activists.
Her charges include conspiracy to commit sex
trafficking of minors, sex trafficking of
a minor sex trafficking and obstruction.
Now, so she was just elected or just chosen,
I guess, as a leader of the Minnesota College
Republicans.
So they've had to come out and issue a statement
condemning these actions and reminding people
like, hey, we were all remote last year, so
we don't know what's actually happening.
But again, the question is, where's the cue,
folks?
Hmm, you say you want to rid the government
of these sex offenders and here's to fairly
high profile Republicans from Minnesota trafficking
allegedly children for sex and people always
get annoyed.
By the way, when you throw out the why do
you say allegedly legally we have to just
so everybody's aware of that, OK?
They have not been charged.
They've been charged.
They have not been convicted.
So everything up to that point is allegedly
OK.
So just so everybody's clear on that, I always
get a lot of people saying, why don't you
just call him that?
Well, because we don't want to get sued.
OK, there's your answer.
But again, where's the queue people?
Hmm?
Where are you when it's one of your own?
Where are you on the mat gate story.
Because we got a lot of good information on
that last week, all those text messages, the
thousands of pieces of evidence being turned
over by Joel Greenberg, the former Seminole
County tax collector down here in Florida
with pictures and videos and text messages
directly implicating Matt Gates in a scheme
to.
Buy sex from an underage girl.
Come on, folks, I mean, I thought this was
what Cuba was all about.
I thought you wanted to bust the pedophiles.
Is they're getting busted or at least the
people trafficking for sex or getting busted.
But nowhere to be found, right?
Disgusting, disgusting, disgusting behavior
and a disgusting conspiracy theory because,
yeah, you know what, there's some real perverts
out there.
If you all put your effort into actually helping
to track these people down and put a stop
to some of these trafficking rings, that would
be worthwhile.
But instead, you'd rather just push these
wild conspiracies that are driving people
insane, as we saw with the California man
last week, murdered his own two kids.
You know what a wasted opportunity if you
actually cared about sex trafficking victims,
you could have done anything to help.
You could have put all of this to use for
good.
But that's never what this was about.
This is about attacking politicians, right?
Well, at least these two got busted and hopefully,
if what they're charged with, you know, if
they actually did it, then, yeah, hopefully
they go away for a long, long time.